[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor john ross hello friends
how about an amazing fact in 1986 the
italian runner
ganny poli won the new york marathon in
two hours and eleven minutes
in 2003 mark yatic of kenya
triumphed at the los angeles marathon in
a time of two hours and ten minutes
but doubtless the most admired runner of
those two marathons
actually finished last and in the
slowest time ever recorded
in 1986 bob weyland finished the new
york marathon
in about 98 hours and in 2003
he crossed the finish line of the los
angeles marathon in a little more than
173 hours
now before you write of bob whelan's
marathons as a complete failure
you need to know that he competed in
both events using
only his arms and torso for you see bob
has no legs
in 1969 while trying to rescue a fallen
buddy in vietnam
he stepped onto a land mine and suffered
massive leg injuries
while in hospital he sent this short
note to his parents
he wrote dear mom and dad i'm in the
hospital
everything is going to be ok the people
here are taking good care of me
love bob and then he added ps i think i
lost my legs
and so he did after what was left of his
legs were amputated
instead of giving up he set out on a
mission to walk across
america on his hands it took him three
years
eight months and six days to go from
coast to coast
using only his arms and torso but that
was only the beginning
twice he made a six thousand two hundred
mile round trip
bike ride across america he's the only
double amputee ever to come
complete the ironman triathlon of kona
hawaii
without a wheelchair he swam 2.4 miles
and then biked 112 miles and finished up
with a 26.2 mile marathon
using only his arms bob whelan is also
the recipient of four world records
including a 500 570 pound
bench press award it is no wonder
that he was nicknamed mr inspiration
the nfl players association awarded him
the title
the most courageous man in america and
people's magazine dubbed him
one of the six most amazing america
americans
after completing the los angeles
marathon at the age of 57
bob told the associated press it was
done by the grace of god he then summed
up his amazing endurance by saying
i do it one step at a time friends did
you know that the bible says that
christians in the last days will also
need to have
amazing endurance stay tuned for more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
hello friends welcome back this is bible
answers live pastor doug bashley's out
this evening my name is john ross and
filling in
is pastor carlos munoz and he is going
to be helping answer bible questions as
well as
work the phone welcome carlos marinata
pastor hey
we're glad you're here amen it's always
fun to be here
before we get to our program why did you
start with the word of prayer sure
father thank you again for uh this
opportunity to come together and spend
time in your word
answering bible questions we know that
the wisdom comes from you
and so we just ask that your spirit
guide us so that uh
to lead us so that we can give the
answers that people are searching for
based on your word so thank you father
for this opportunity and we ask us in
jesus name
amen amen pastor carlos we opened the
program talking about bob
whelan i had somebody heard about this
gentleman before but um you can actually
research him you can you can google him
and they've got some pictures
and without a doubt you can see he's
very strong in his arms and his chest
his upper body
but you know he could have given up
after such a terrible tragedy of losing
his legs and just think well you know
i'm just going to take it easy but no he
had incredible
endurance persistence he wanted to make
a difference he wanted to inspire
other people that despite difficulties
or physical challenges
they can overcome if they persist and so
he became known as misty encouragement
and inspiration
and he was well known for his endurance
you know i read this fact i was thinking
about a verse in the bible it's actually
the words of jesus and it's talking
about our time you read in matthew
24 verse 11 jesus said and many false
prophets will rise up and deceive many
and because lawlessness will abound the
love of many will grow cold but
here's the point he that endures to the
end
the same shall be saved jesus says at
the end
you're going to need endurance
christians are going to have to
endurance now uh
carlos we're not talking about physical
endurance although i'm sure it's good to
have physical endurance but what jesus
is talking about here more than anything
else is spiritual endurance amen
uh spiritual endurance to seek and know
the truth because there's going to be
many false prophets that'll arise in the
last days
their goal is to deceive and then you
read in revelation chapter 14 verse 12
about a group of people it says here is
the patience or the endurance of the
saints here are those who keep the
commandments of god
and they have the faith of jesus they
also have the testimony of jesus you
read in revelation 12
17. so god's people in the last days not
only known for
being obedient in keeping his
commandments but they also have the
faith of jesus not just faith in jesus
but actually verse 12 revelation 14 12
says the faith of jesus they need to
have
endurance they need to have perseverance
well how can we have that kind of
faith that endurance that the bible
speaks of you know we do have a book
that we'll be happy to send out to
anyone who calls and asks
it's entitled assurance justification
made
simple how do we nurture that faith the
bible says faith comes by hearing
hearing by the word of god and one of
the great assurances that we have in
scripture is that god loves us god
forgives us and that god gives us
grace and strength and as we trust in
him our faith can grow
and that is going to be a free offer
we're going to be happy to send that to
anyone who
calls and asks anyone in north america
and the number to call if you'd like to
receive
that book written by pastor doug called
assurance justification made simple
the number is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book it's
called assurance justification
made simple and if you have a bible
question our phone lines are open this
is a good chance if you have your
question to
get on the air this evening the number
is 800-463-7297 that is our
toll-free uh phone line here to the
studio we'd also like to greet our
friends who are joining us not only on
the radio but also on facebook we know
there are many people
not only in north america carlos but
central america
and around the world that tune in
because we get people calling us from
australia and even africa so
we'd like to greet our friends who are
joining us online again our phone lines
are open this is a good time for you to
pick up your phone and give us a call
well pastor carlos who is our first
caller for this evening
we have chris from florida
chris good evening you're on the air
yes thank you pastor
yes welcome chris thank you for taking
my call i i have a very basic
maybe childish sounding
question but how do we know how do i
know
that i am a chosen one before
foundation of the world like like a
paul says in one of his letters
okay how do we know if we're a chosen
one well the bible makes it clear that
those who are chosen are the ones who
choose christ if you are christ then
your abraham seed heirs according to the
promises
it's not an arbitrary choice that god
makes as to who's going to be saved and
who's going to be lost
but god desires everyone to be saved the
bible says god is not willing that any
should perish but that all should come
to repentance
jesus said in that famous verse john 3
whoever believes in me shall not perish
but have everlasting life so
the gospel invitation is for everyone it
is to everyone
revelation chapter 14 you read about the
everlasting gospel going to every nation
kindred tongue and people
those who respond to the gospel those
who receive
jesus as their personal savior they are
the ones who are chosen they are chosen
for eternal life
so we make a decision god responds to
that decision
and he chooses us that doesn't mean that
we can never
change our mind god does not force
anyone to be saved
but if we choose him he chooses us and
you know we have that assurance that
hope now we are chosen from the
foundation of the world meaning that
through christ
those who respond to the gospel a
provision has been made so that they can
be saved a
sacrifice is being provided and that
sacrifice is jesus
does that help chris yes yes yes sir but
there is another there are other things
that we have to comply with like
obedience correct well it begins with
faith you know the first thing we do is
we come to jesus just the way that we
are
we confess our sins we ask him to
forgive us we receive him as our
personal savior that's where it begins
if we ask and believe we have confidence
to know that god hears he answers
he will cleanse us from sin but then we
need to
every day commit ourselves to him the
apostle paul says i die daily meaning
that we need to surrender self
every day to christ and just as surely
as we do that trusting in him
he will work a work within us pastor
carlos that we cannot do for ourselves
amen and that's the power of the gospel
right amen and that's good news so
our work is to choose him to surrender
to him
and ask him to do a work that only he
can do
you know chris we have a book it's
called three steps to heaven and it
talks about
what can we do in order to enter into
this saving relationship with christ
and of course we'll be happy to send
this to you or anyone that calls and
asks it's such an important question
what do i have to do to be saved you
know carlos that was a question that was
asked even back in bible times
they asked the apostles men and brethren
what shall we do to be saved and the
answer was repent and be baptized
we'll be happy to send this book to
anyone who calls and asks it's called
three steps to heaven
and the number to call for that is
four 800-835-6747 and we'll send it to
you if you're outside of north america
you can read the book by simply going to
the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.org
and if you have a bible question one
more time the number here is eight
hundred
four six three two
with your bible question all right
next question we have lynette from angel
camp
california good evening lynette you are
on the air
good evening how are you we're blessed
doing well thank you
good good okay my question concerns
um in the account at first samuel um
chapter 28 verses three through 20. the
account of when
samuel had died saul was about to
confront the philistines
and he was afraid so he consulted a
medium
who summoned a spirit and
it appeared in the form of samuel who
gave
kind of a prediction that samuel
would not survive this battle which
ended up to be true now we no it wasn't
samuel
um what who
i mean it's confusing to me a little bit
so you're wondering how did this the
spirit that was not samuel
so the only other would be an evil
spirit how did an evil spirit know
that saul was going to be killed in
battle the next day
yeah okay uh well first of all the devil
knew and these evil spirits knew that at
this point saul had hardened his heart
he had rejected god
so the protection that god had typically
given to those who trust in him had been
withdrawn or removed and if you're not
protected by god
then you are vulnerable to the devil and
the devil's attacks
so i think the devil knew very well that
saul had sort of passed the point of no
return he had rebelled against god he
had hardened his heart
the spirit of god the protection of god
had been withdrawn from saul
and in essence he was really at the the
whim
of these evil spirits at the womb of the
devil and the devil knew what he was
going to do to saul
so um yeah that's why if saul had
remained faithful to god
the devil couldn't have done anything to
saul god would have protected him
does that does that matter you think
that the yeah so you think that the
devil actually
caused the death that's why i didn't
make the prediction that it was going to
happen in battle he actually
caused the death he had something to do
with it without a doubt yes
okay yep and that's exactly what
happened to him
okay well thank you very much i
appreciate it all right thanks your coal
all right next we have noah from rock
falls
illinois noah good evening you are on
the air
good evening pastor ross and good
evening carlos
good evening and your question tonight
my question is i'm trying to witness to
one of my neighbors
and they asked me to go to a bar with
them and i didn't feel
comfortable would it be okay for a
christian
to go to a bar witness to somebody
okay um you know first of all i think
the best witness that a christian can be
is is not to be in a bar i mean you
might even want to say to the person you
know i'd like to visit with you and
share with you these things but
you know i'm not comfortable going to a
bar because i don't think that's
a best witness that i could be now there
are situations perhaps where somebody
needs to go
into a bar and maybe help bring somebody
out who is in need
but to set up a bible study in a bar
probably is not
the right place you could think of a lot
better places to set up a bible study we
can visit with someone
the environment there in a bar the music
the noise
smoking the smoking the alcohol it just
seems that whatever good you're trying
to do
in witnessing you have so many things
opposed to that there are so many
distractions
that it would probably be better to find
a different place where you place where
you can
we can sit down and visit with this
person
all right thank you yeah all right
thanks noah and they're not in a bar all
day long so
yeah you know you can you can find a
different place
somewhere else all right who else do we
have next we have rose from bullhead
city
arizona good evening rose you're on the
air
hi say i have a question about
planting a seed in an abstinent
non-believer
who actually believes in evolution and
science
and um i'm having trouble just getting
him to listen so i just want to know
where what
seed can i plant that maybe the next
person might continue on with
sure you know i think one of the first
things we can do is
um by our example by our faith by our
life
we can demonstrate that we do have
confidence
we can trust the lord we know how the
story ends
there's a lot of people in the world
today who are concerned who are worried
the bible says in the last days people's
hearts will be failing then because of
fear
seeing the things that are happening and
coming upon the world
but the believer can have faith and
confidence and trust in god so if
if we trust in the lord and there is a
peace and a joy that we have in our
hearts
that will be a telling influence on
others your second part of the question
is well if this person
you know is a believer in let's say for
example evolution he doesn't believe in
god
um you can ask certain questions to kind
of get him to think a little bit
and i know pastor carlos is here and and
probably the catalyst
carlos in your search for truth had to
do somewhat with
uh studying science and you began to
wonder raise more questions than
than answers yeah i was i was blown away
with the the detail
with the complexity with the uh how the
holistic
aspect of how everything is connected
and there's no
nothing is is random everything has a
purpose and that's completely opposite
to what evolution teaches
they teach that there is no there's no
order there's no reason behind it
and so and the reason is because they're
trying to deny god because it would be
easier to say that there is a purpose
behind it but then you there's somebody
behind the purpose
so yeah it's it's it's really prayer is
the key
with how to deal with somebody that
believes in evolution because
there might be other reasons why they
believe in evolution besides the
the core science and so so one of the
things as you say pastor carlos you
might want to ask some key questions to
kind of get them thinking
something related to you know isn't it
amazing how
everything is interdependent how could
something have evolved when
in order for it to have life all of
these different pieces have to be in
place
even yesterday i was thinking even
yesterday i was thinking how is it that
every species on the earth has a male
and female
right is that just coincidence that
every single species came up with the
same
equation i mean it doesn't make sense
right right
it shows that there's a there there is
logic behind it there's there's a design
so you know those are some of the things
you can bring up rose and and try and uh
plant some seeds but
probably the greatest is through your
witness through
through your faith through the peace
that god puts in your heart
and then planting those little seeds and
praying for the person praying that the
lord
would lead and guide in their life so um
keep up the good work
and we'll be praying for you and we have
a we have a free book
on a library too on that i was just
looking it up
it's amazing wonders of creation oh we
do that's right i'm looking at it right
here
rose we have a book it's called we
haven't really offered this very often
but
we'll be happy to send it to you it's
called amazing wonders of creation it
talks about some of these things in
nature that
prove intelligent design and
if you'd like to receive that the number
to call is 800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for the book
it's called amazing wonders of creation
you might want to read that give it to
your friend and say take a look at this
see what you think and maybe that'll get
the person thinking hey man
thanks for your call who do we have next
next we have diane she's calling from
british columbia canada
good evening diane you're on the air hey
good evening
gentlemen how are you doing well thank
you
good good so my question is regarding
daniel
9 when it's talking about the 70 weeks
in verse 25
it talks about towards the end of 25 it
talks about
how it'll be built again and the walls
thereof so the street and the walls
and then in 26 it says that the end will
come
with a flood and i'm just wondering what
those things are talking about
okay very good good question uh the
question that's been asked
in daniel actually near the end of
chapter eight and then it's followed
through hearing daniel
the two issues that's been addressed is
what's going to happen to jerusalem
remember daniel at the time was
a captive in babylon when he received
the vision
so the question was what's going to
happen to jerusalem the city at the time
was still
in ruins the temple was destroyed
but according to the prophecies they
knew that they would go back and they'd
rebuild the temple in jerusalem but what
would be the ultimate result for
jerusalem the second part
has to do with the messiah when will the
messiah come what will his work be
so in verse 25 the angel is now giving
some very important keys to help
understand
when the messiah would come and what
would ultimately happen to jerusalem
the literal city of jerusalem so in
verse 25 no therefore
understand that from the going forth of
the command to restore and rebuild
jerusalem
now the jews were captives in babylon
the decree was given in 457 bc
457 bc the decree was given they were
actually three decrees the third one
by artaxerxes allowed the jews to go
back and rebuild not only the temple
but also the city and rebuild the walls
so that's the starting point of the time
prophecy 457 bc
and to say from that going forth to
restore and rebuild jerusalem unto
messiah the prince that's the anointing
of the prince
there will be seven weeks and 62 weeks
so a total of 69 weeks
one prophetic day is equal to one
literal year so if you do the math it
works out to
27 a.d when the messiah would be
anointed
that was at the baptism of jesus when he
was anointed with the holy spirit when
he started his public ministry
and then it goes on to talk about the
city it says the street will be built
again in the wall even in troublesome
times that's
exactly what happened when the jews went
back and they started to rebuild
jerusalem and the walls
they had opposition from the samaritans
and from others that hindered the work
but finally the work was done
then verse 26 goes back to talk about
the messiah and it says
after 62 weeks so it's after 27 a.d
sometime after 27 a.d messiah will be
cut off but not for himself it's talking
about the crucifixion of jesus
then it goes on to say the last part of
verse 26 and the people of the prince
who is to come shall destroy the city
and the sanctuary the inn shall
be with the flood the people of the
prince there is
the romans that came and destroyed
jerusalem
in 70 a.d and that prophecy met a
amazing fulfillment where it says the
city
and the sanctuary shall be destroyed
with a flood now when it's talking about
a flood it's talking about a flood of
people
but it's also talking about a massive
slaughter of life
the story in josephus describes uh the
overthrow of jerusalem and it says the
blood flowed down the temple
stairs like water so it was a terrible
destruction of life
in the last part of verse 26 it says
till the end war and desolations is
determined
so that would ultimately happen to
jerusalem and it met its fulfillment in
70 a.d so those are
uh the two main focuses of this vision
the interpretation is the messiah the
prince
and what happens to jerusalem all right
thank you very much appreciate it
all right thanks you call diane next we
have robert
from college place washington good
evening robert you're on the air
evening carlos evening pastor ross hello
hi there
hello um i heard
uh i just reading uh on amazing facts
that
i guess you're on up tv right now which
is really really cool
yeah we're always looking for new uh
outlets to um
utilize for our program so yes we're
always expanding that
yeah i i sent in a donation today to for
to help with that we appreciate that
that's what helps us
keep these programs on the air and your
your question tonight robert it's uh
job 27 verse 3 uh i i know about
the spirit being being the breath
but the that verse kind of kind of uh
puzzles me or whatever you want to call
it where
it talks about the spirit of god being
in my nostrils um
it just this seems or sounds kind of
weird i mean
yeah yeah does the holy spirit
yeah does the holy spirit live in our
nose no no that's not what it's saying
remember
job is riding in prophetic prose and we
have many examples of this a number of
the psalms also written in these types
of prose
you've got ecclesiastes which is also
written in prose
and really it's referring to god being
the source of life
god is the one that gives us our breath
now when it's talking about the breath
here it's not just talking about
us breathing in and out although we know
that's important for life
but there is that spark of life that
essence of life that only comes from god
god is the one that gives life the devil
cannot create life
it comes from god and that is described
here as this breath of the spirit the
word is used interchangeably here in the
old testament
so the breath that we breathe in and out
is a symbol of that
spark of life that essence of life that
god gives
so again it's just written in poetic
language that you find here in job 27
verse 3.
so um if uh
a person dies then and
the spirit of god it is taken
well i mean it goes back to god the
spirit or the breath goes back to god
yes
and since god is eternal that doesn't
mean that
that the spirit that our breath is
eternal is all right
well when it's talking about the spirit
of god or the spirit of life that
that god has that he gives to all living
things it's not our intelligent being it
doesn't have
understanding it doesn't have character
doesn't have personality it's just that
spark of life and
not only do we have life but all living
things share that life you've got
animals that have life and plants that
have life and
all of the life that we see in the world
around us comes from god
god is the one that provides or brings
that life
so when a person dies that breath of
life or that spirit of life
returns to god but it doesn't mean that
our conscious
being or our soul goes up to heaven or
returns to god
it's just talking about that essence of
life that that power
that sparkle of life yeah
i was going to read genesis chapter 7
verse 22
it says all in whose nostrils was the
breath of the spirit of life
all that was on the dry land died it's
talking about all created beings in that
context of the flood
so it's not only people there's talking
about annual animals as well yep
anything that
receives its life from god and it's
talking about the judgment that comes
at the time of the flood and of course
we know that uh the flood is a type of a
judgment that comes at the end of time
and again god is going to purify the
earth not with water but the bible tells
us it's going to be with fire at the
very end
but then he creates a new heavens and a
new earth
where he dwells righteousness because
that is the great hope of the christian
and that is what we are looking at
you know perhaps carlos i'm looking at
the clock we're coming up on our half
hour break so the program's not over by
any means
we're just gonna get a drink of water
and catch our breath here
uh if you have a bible question the
phone lines are open 800-463-7297
that'll bring you here to the studio and
in just a few moments we'll be back to
take more bible answers life
we'll speak with you in just a moment
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800 463
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends welcome back this is bible
answers live my name is john ross and
joining me is pastor carlos munoz
pastor doug is out this evening but as
you can tell this is a live interactive
international bible study and we'd love
to hear from you if you have a bible
related question our phone lines are
open
the number is 800 4637
and if you don't get through right away
we just encourage you to hold on have
some endurance as we spoke about at the
beginning of the program hold on we will
get to as many calls as possible
and pastor carlos for that let's get to
our next caller yes we have abraham from
california
good evening abraham you are on the air
um my question is
when god brings down his kingdom
to the mountain of olives uh
how much days would it be when satan
prepares his people like
days months or weeks or hours
all right well good question abraham let
me ask uh how old are you
uh eight years old eight years old boy
that's a good
deep question for an eight-year-old glad
you called and asked abraham
all right just to bring our friends up
to to speed with what you're talking
about in revelation chapter
20 we have a description of something
called the thousand years
sometimes known as the millennium at the
beginning of the millennium we have the
second coming of christ
and the dead in christ are raised and
they caught up to meet jesus in the air
the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of christ coming during the
thousand years the redeemed or in heaven
the devil is bound on the earth for the
thousand years
and i'll read a verse it's uh revelation
chapter 20 verse 1
it says then i saw an angel come down
from heaven having a key to the
bottomless pit
and a great chain in his hand and he
laid hold of the dragon that old serpent
of all called the devil and satan and
bound him for a thousand years
but verse three says cast him into this
bottomless pit and shut him up and set a
seal on him that he should deceive the
nations no more till the thousand years
were finished
now the reason the devil can't deceive
anyone is because the righteous
are safe in heaven the wicked have been
destroyed with the brightness of
christ's coming so the devil is here on
this earth
it's just him and his angels but then
the last part of verse 3 and this gets
to your question abraham it says but
after these things
he must be released for a little while
now we don't know how long that little
while is the bible just says a little
while so at the end of the thousand
years
when the dead are resurrected that is
the wicked that are resurrected for
what the bible calls the great white
throne judgment
um satan is released from his prison
meaning he can go and deceive those
nations
and you look in verse 6 of revelation
chapter 20 it says
holy blessed and holy is he that is part
on this first resurrection over such the
second death has no power
but then verse 7 says now when the
thousand years were ended
satan will release be released from his
prison
he will go out and deceive the nations
which are on the four corners of the
earth gog and magog
to gather them to battle whose number is
just the sand of the sea
so at the end of the thousand years the
dead are resurrected the devil is going
to go out and deceive them how long will
that be
well the bible doesn't tell us whether
it's a month or a year or a week
it just calls it a little season so
whatever that might be we don't know it
could be weeks could be months
i don't think it's going to drag on for
years because i think
at that point it's a matter of bringing
this rebellion finally to an end
the redeemed are looking forward to the
new heavens and the new earth that is
soon to be created
after the final judgment and the
destruction of the wicked
thank you for your call abraham you know
we do have a study guide it's called a
thousand years of peace
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who wants to learn more about
this thousand year millennium that we
read about in revelation chapter 20.
i just call and ask for it the number is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called a thousand years of peace and
we'll mail that to anyone in north
america if you're outside of north
america
just go to the amazing facts website you
can type in there in the free library a
thousand years of peace and you'll be
able to read the study guide right there
who do we have next next we have taylor
from oregon taylor you're on the air
hi hello mike hi
yeah and your question my question is
um does god show himself in dreams
well um the answer to that is
yes he can he can show himself in dreams
and we have many examples in the bible
of people that had a dream that
had that came from god even pagans had
dreams that came from god i think of
nebuchadnezzar the king of babylon he
had a dream
he had more than one actually two
significant dreams that we have recorded
in the book of daniel that came from god
so god can't speak to a person in a
dream however having said that we need
to be careful
because not every dream even though it
might be vivid it might seem very
powerful
it might even seem to indicate something
that we should do
not every dream necessarily comes from
god as i think we realize
often dreams is just the multitude of
activities
and things happening during the day the
brain sometimes will sort of
reboot itself and organize and
categorize these different
ideas and memories so we got to test
even dreams by the word of god if we
have a dream and
it seems that an angel is telling us to
do something but what that angel is
telling us to do contradicts the word of
god then we know that dream is not from
god because god won't contradict his
word
but yes there are times where god might
speak to a person through a dream to
bring
encouragement and hope to encourage them
to be faithful to obey
so yes god can't speak through dreams
all right thank you all right thanks for
call all right
praise the lord next we have carl
carline carla carlian from sacramento
good evening carlyanne
hi carleen how are you there yes welcome
yes this is carly ann hi how are you hi
thanks for calling
thank you so much um my question was
what happens
if you're overcome by the holy spirit
and start speaking in tongues while
praying but
don't know what you're saying i remember
reading in scripture something about
um you know it's not good to speak in
tongues that there's like not an
interpreted
interpreter there or you're not able to
interpret it yourself
yes um now first of all let's just talk
about what
what a tongue means in the bible um
a tongue simply means a language so when
the bible speaks of somebody
speaking or praying in an unknown tongue
that language is not unknown to them
but it's unknown to the other people to
whom they are
preaching or teaching or worshiping with
so for example i'll read first
corinthians chapter 14.
here is probably the verse you referring
to it says for if i pray in a tongue my
spirit prays but my understanding is
unfruitful
what is the conclusion then i will pray
in the spirit i will also pray with the
understanding
i will sing in the spirit i will also
sing with the understanding
so here paul is talking about a church
service and he's saying if i get up and
i speak a language or i pray
in a language that nobody present
understands
i'm unfruitful meaning my prayer is
meaningless to the people who are
hearing it
doesn't mean paul doesn't understand
what he's saying paul spoke many
languages
the church at corinth was sort of at a
crossroads
people would travel through corinth some
of them would speak greek others would
speak hebrew others would speak other
languages in the area
and you'd find all of these people
coming to the church and they would
be there in their own language sometimes
they would want to speak in their
language and
paul is saying if you get up and pray in
a language that nobody else understands
you're not really benefiting them you
might be blessed
but you're not helping them because they
can't understand you
that's why he says it's better to have
somebody interpret what you're saying
that's why the rest of the verse in
verse 15 he says what then do we
conclude
i will pray in the spirit i will also
pray with the understanding meaning
when i pray i'll make sure that the
people that are there can understand
that
i might need a translator but i want to
make sure they can understand
so for instance i was praying over a
girl
before i did cpr on her and
i started speaking in tongues but i i
didn't understand what i was saying i
was just overcome by the holy spirit so
i think that like the inner spirit maybe
was interceding at that point because i
didn't really know what to do or say
maybe well you know sometimes i think a
person might cry out to god and the
bible says that the spirit
intercedes on our behalf because he
knows
even better than we do uh what we are
longing for what the heart's desire is
and he can present our request to god
but there are many examples in the bible
when a person prayed and asked for
something they prayed with their
understanding even jesus in the garden
when he prayed he said
father if it is possible let this cup
pass nevertheless not my will die will
be done
so um you know god knows and understands
your heart and i think in that moment
you're you know you were overwhelmed
praying and saying lord i don't even
know what to say
but when we pray we want to pray with
understanding because
not only then is it a blessing to us
because we know what we are saying
but it's a blessing as well to those who
might be around us
we can be a witness that way okay so we
need so i
basically just need to pray for the
understanding
of of speaking in tongues well when you
pray
you know speak uh prayer has been
defined as opening your heart to god as
you would to a friend
if you have a very best friend that you
are talking to and
you're troubled about something and
you're sharing that with your friend
uh you might not be the most eloquent in
your description because
you know your heart's heavy but you will
try and communicate in a way that they
could understand
and when we pray we want to communicate
to god uh our heart
we might not always use the right words
it might not always come out
with beautiful language but god knows
our heart sometimes all we can do is
just
you know be in his presence and say lord
here i am you know my heart you know
what i need
yeah exactly thank you so much i
appreciate your time all right thanks
for calling
we have a we do have a book it's called
understanding tongues and it deals with
this passage in first corinthians
and we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who would call and ask
and uh colleen i would encourage you to
call and ask for that the number is
800-835-6747 and ask for the book we'll
send it to you for free it's called
understanding tongues it's talking about
the gift of the spirit here when it's
talking about tongues and i think you'll
be blessed by that amen who do we have
next next we have lee fett
from milford pennsylvania good evening
lee fit
hi good evening thank you so much for
taking my call yes thanks for calling
i'm calling about hebrews chapter 6
4-6 okay
let me go ahead and read the verse just
so that there might be people driving
and
they can hear the verse hebrews chapter
6 4 says for
it is impossible for those who are once
enlightened to have tasted the heavenly
gift
and have become partakers of the holy
spirit and have tasted the good word of
god and the powers of the age to come
if they fall away to renew them again to
repentance since they crucify
again for themselves the son of god and
put into open shame
right and your question on that
well so i need a little bit more
understanding because
i was under the oppression that when
people do backslide
they have an opportunity to come back to
the lord
so what it what is this scripture who is
this
scripture speaking to exactly um
because it sounds like they have lost an
opportunity
yes am i missing i i must be
misinterpreting that in some way
or the i think the key there is verse
six where it says if they fall away
to renew them again to repentance the
way it's translating the english fall
away it gives the impression of
almost a one-time sin so you're a
believer but then you fall away
maybe for a few days or so and then you
can't come back to god no that's not
what the original
meaning there is the falling away is a
deliberate
rejection turning away walking away
and rejecting the holy spirit you see
the bible tells us that it's the
goodness of god that leads us to
repentance
jesus said every sin will be forgiven
man except blasphemy against the holy
spirit or
rejection of the holy spirit so if
somebody over and over again
rejects the spirit speaking to his heart
he hardens his heart
like pharaoh did to the point where he
can't come to repentance or he doesn't
want to come to repentance
he has no interest in coming to
repentance his heart is hardened
right that's the unpardonable sin oh
that's the sin that can't be forgiven
so that's what's been addressed in this
passage it's not talking about
a christian that might stumble and fall
the bible says
if we sin we are to confess our sins god
is faithful and just to forgive us and
to cleanse us from all unrighteousness
and we have so many examples in the
bible of people who did
fall away but they came to repentance
and god forgave him
one of the great examples that we have
in the new testament is the story of
peter
who was a believer but then he denied
christ and said i do not know him but
then he went and
wept bitterly and he was forgiven so
um clearly there are examples of people
that have turned back to god and
you know i think all of us would be in
trouble if god just said you know you
have one chance and if you don't get it
right that's the end of it um
god is merciful he wants to save and if
we confess our sins he's faithful and
just to forgive us
perfect thank you so much i really
appreciate all right thanks your call
good question god bless you thank you
next we have brian from grand junction
colorado
brian you're on the air hey guys
first time caller how are you doing well
thanks for calling
all right so ran across some
uh cool stuff in psalm 82
6. yes i believe it's referring to
the uh leaders of israel
being called as god
you see this jesus referring to that in
john
10 when they're trying to get him at the
synagogue you know referring back to
your law says that your god's
you know why is it blasphemy for me to
to be
the son of god so i'm just curious what
you guys
kind of think of
just you know what's the verses sure
uh psalm 82 6
and i think it's john 10 11 where yep
jesus jesus refers to that and it goes
all the way back to
exodus with moses and aaron as well
but okay yeah let me let me say here's
what you guys think of that
yeah yeah let me share a few thoughts on
that you know first of all this verse
has confused some people
and there are some that misinterpret
this to give the idea that we're all
in some way gods um but that's not what
the bible teaches
uh when you refer to verse six and he
said you are gods
and all of your children are the most
high you shall be
you shall die like them and and fall one
of the princes
it's talking specifically here to the
leaders in israel
who stood in the place of god to the
people
they were the priests they would teach
the law they would
present the gospel and they were corrupt
in the work that they were doing
and the warning came you shall fall like
all men
so even though they for example moses
and aaron
they were representatives of god to the
people they were not god
they were not gods but they represented
god it was a very sobering work
and an important responsibility that a
priest would bear or a prophet would
bear
or a leader an alden israel would bear
and if you want to put that in our
modern terms that would be
a pastor or a bible teacher
someone in a position of authority to
teach and preach the word of god
it is a very sobering and important work
and jesus refers to this where he says
he actually quotes this in psalms 82
verse 6.
he's talking to the religious leaders
who
claim that they did have some extra
grace
and were more spiritual than anyone else
because they were part of the pharisees
or
the priesthood and jesus is saying you
will die like others
just because you're in that position it
doesn't give you freedom to
to continue in sin and misrepresent
god's character to the people
yeah also i would add that the word for
judge for god's here is the word elohim
and in other parts of scripture it
appears as the word judge
so they were in a place of judgment yep
and of course the word god's there is
the small
gee it's not a capitalist right i didn't
catch that yeah
even the bible translate is realized
it's not talking about
the god of heaven you never see that
stuff anywhere like that
just like huh people butcher that up so
yeah no that's a good point that you you
brought out and that verse has confused
people but if you study a little further
look at it in context it's it's
referring to the leaders or the judges
that are in israel right all right well
thanks for your call brian good question
next we have tammy from periodi illinois
good evening tammy good evening pastors
hi tammy thanks for calling thank you
this is my first time calling welcome
i know that when we die our bodies
are a shell and our souls go to heaven
or hell i do believe in the father son
and the holy ghost
and i want to be cremated and what i
would like to know
is if i'm cremated can i
put my ashes in more than one grave or
one
in more than one place will my soul
still go to heaven
okay well hey i got good i got good news
for you first of all
the good news is that when jesus comes
again and he resurrects the righteous
he doesn't use any of this current
existing material
so we get brand new bodies at the second
coming of christ
um the bible speaks about mortal putting
on immortality meaning that these mortal
bodies
uh are like the body that jesus had when
he rose from the dead
and he had an immortal body it was a
real body but it was a
immortal body and of course he traveled
up to heaven and the redeemed are going
to travel to heaven and travel through
space we don't need
to have a space suit or something like
that
so we get brand new bodies it doesn't
matter whether these bodies are buried
and turned to ashes or sprinkled in the
ocean
um god doesn't need any of the leftovers
to make us new he's got a perfect
dna print of who we are of our
personality of our character
he knows who we are and he's going to
resurrect us now
when a person dies their next conscious
thought is the resurrection
so when a person dies they don't
immediately see themselves
floating through the air if they're a
bad person they don't immediately go to
judgment and the fires of hell they're
simply
asleep in the grave until the
resurrection
so for the righteous you are resurrected
the moment jesus comes
i might die today and my very next
conscious thought will be
i am resurrected i'm being caught up in
the air and jesus is coming
i might not be aware that you know 100
years has passed
to me it's just a moment of twinkling
over the eye
so nobody's burning in heaven yeah
nobody's burning in hell now
the bible speaks about hell and
destruction of the wicked happening at
the end of the thousand years
and that's yet in the future so we don't
have to worry about what's going to
happen to our soul when we die
god will resurrect us and we will have
brand new bodies when he comes again
our very next conscious thought after we
die
is the second coming of christ and we
are caught up to meet him in the air
okay that's good information thank you
past pastors for taking my calling
have a blessed night you're welcome
thanks for calling tammy you know we do
have a
a study guide that talks about what
happens when a person dies
and it's called are the dead really dead
and you know you don't think of
the subject of death as being a very
hopeful subject but when you look at
what the bible says about death
especially for the believer it is a very
hopeful
subject jesus likened death to sleep
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks
the number is 800-835-6747 you can ask
for the study guide are the dead really
dead
who do we have next next we have cindy
from
cala mesa california good evening cindy
you are on the air
hi thank you for taking my call tonight
thanks for calling cindy
so i have a question about matthew
16 18 and 19
and and it says i will tell you that you
are peter and on this rock i will build
my church
and the gates of hades will not prevail
against it
i will give you the keys of the kingdom
of heaven whatever you
bind on earth will be bound in heaven
and whatever you loose on earth will be
loosed in heaven
so i've been studying this verse and i
find
that in in some of the translations
it it talks in the future tense tense
so whatever you whatever you loose on
earth
will be loosed in heaven and then in
some of the translations
it talks in the past tense and it says
whatever you loose on earth
will have already been loosed in heaven
and whatever you bind on earth will
already have been
bound in heaven and so
my question as to parts one does the
tenth make a difference
uh pastor or future and
and then kind of a explanation of the
whole thing
okay great question all right let me
quickly starting in verse 18
jesus is speaking to peter and he says
upon this rock i'll build my church
now jesus specifically says you are
peter the word there
peter means a pebble or a stone there's
a word play
jesus is using a word play the word
peter petros
is means a stone or a pebble
then jesus says you are a stone or a
pebble but on this
rock i will build my church the church
is not built on peter the church is
built upon
christ jesus is the rock jesus said
whoever hears these sayings of mine
and does them is like the wise man who
builds upon the rock
christ is the foundation of the church
then he says the gates of hell won't
prevail against
it the it in the verse is the church so
if christ is the foundation of the
church
and we're obedient to him the devil can
come up against the church
but he won't be able to overcome the
church because it's founded upon jesus
but then in verse 19 jesus says will
give you the keys of the kingdom
and whatever you bind on earth will be
bound in heaven whatever you loose on
earth will be loosed in heaven
what did jesus give peter and the
disciples
that would open or close heaven to other
people
well jesus gave them the gospel and
jesus said go
take the gospel preach the gospel those
who receive the gospel
they will be saved those who reject the
gospel
they will be lost so the key
that's been referred to here is the
gospel that jesus gave the disciples to
preach to the world
it's not an arbitrary decision peter
doesn't say oh i think you can be saved
and you can be lost i'm going to
let you in heaven i'm going to let you
out peter's not guarding the gate of
heaven
but what did the disciples have and
peter represents the disciples
what did jesus give the disciples he
gave them his teaching he gave them the
gospel
and that's why the great commission that
you find in matthew 28 is to take the
gospel to every nation
kindred tongue and people to preach the
gospel those who receive the gospel
they're saved those who reject the
gospel they lost
so that's really what jesus is saying
here and peter represents
the apostles and in a very real sense we
also have those keys
because we get to preach the gospel too
and
people can either close heaven if they
reject the gospel or they can open
heaven if they receive the gospel
so is that what it means by whatever you
bind on earth will be bound in heaven
yes in other words if you preach the
gospel and somebody receives the gospel
that will be noted in heaven if you
preach the gospel
and somebody rejects the gospel that
also is noted in heaven
so how a person responds to the gospel
will determine what record is given
of them in heaven and that's what it
means where it says it shall be noted in
heaven
and then the the versions that say has
already been that doesn't make a
difference it just means
god knows the beginning from the end yes
it doesn't matter whether it's the
past tense or the present tense there
it's just stating the fact that
throughout the christian
era when the gospel is preached those
who receive it they save those
rejected are lost well that's such a
good question cindy thank you so much
but you hear the music in the background
friends we are running out of time if we
didn't get to your question tonight
we encourage you to call us back next
week when we do more bible questions
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
do you feel as though your world is
spiraling out of control
or perhaps new life challenges are
frightening you more than they should
are you sinking while you're thinking
excessive worry can consume you
eating you from the inside out resulting
in sickness
insomnia and paralyzing fear it can also
damage
relationships ruin opportunities and yes
diminish your witness for the gospel
worry affects
everybody differently but it's all
driven by fear
so how can you overcome a world full of
reasons to be anxious
i'd like to recommend for you my new
book finding peace in a world of worry
you'll discover a lifeline to victory a
place where you can cast your cares upon
christ
and experience a serenity that isn't
subject to your circumstances
get your copy of pastor doug's finding
peace in a world of worry today
call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
deep within the pages of the bible
stories of great heroes
heroes of great deeds
great love and great sacrifice
but behind them is another hero hidden
in plain sight
amid the shadows he was there
from the beginning and he'll be there
until the end discover the golden thread
of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing jesus in
all the bible get your copy today
by calling 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.com
and sign up for our free bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
did you enjoy this program make sure to
tell your family and friends
tune in next time for more bible answers
live
honest and accurate answers to your
bible questions